cacher ses ventres que Sainte-Maxime ne
saurait voir dans le centre-ville les
bikini les torse nu se font rares et
c'est à dire que la répression anti Mayo
ferrage oubliant tout complexe nous
avons tenté l'expérience la réaction a
été rapide la météo sur le dos pour moi
ça sera plus récent
et si j'ai rien
vous retourne le 12 vous êtes voilà pas
de verbalisation on vous demande
simplement gentiment d'aller enfiler une
chemise en se référant à l'arrêté
municipale la réalité qui est affichée
dans la mairie la plupart du temps c'est
le petit string il y en a même qui se
promène Les seins nus dans la rue bon je
dis pas sur la plage c'est très bien
mais en ville c'est pas concevable c'est
pas normal il y a des gens qui mangent
c'est pas agréable déjà quand on est
beau c'est c'est une chose mais alors
quand on voit des bouddhas et des
horreurs comme on peut voir qui se
permettent de mettre de l'argent dans
l'herbe je trouve ça lamentable il faut
pas qu'il soit trop trop dénudé quand
même un petit maillot de bain pas trop
décolleté moi je pense que c'est pas mal
quoi